oh hello there we didn't expect to see
you today is this thing on well if
you're here i suppose it's because you
want to hear about an anomaly so which
one will it be today well that's strange
scp-2439 that one's nothing no not like
a pattern screamer such as
scp-000 or
scp-3930 where it's literally a
conscious manifestation existing between
torturous layers of nothingness or
scp-055 the anti-meme where there is
something in there but it's just
impossible to remember or articulate i
mean it's literally just an empty
designation we haven't allocated an
anomaly to that number yet so i suppose
this is just going to be a really short
video well that was easy what now ah
seen any good movies lately you know i
was in the site 19 break room the other
day and dr bright recommended me a great
one called okay okay this thing on good
looks like we're up and running first
things first if you ain't a d-class
click off this video right now don't
watch a second more understood because
if you ain't a d-class and you keep
watching you're putting yourself in a
whole world of danger you got that this
is a video for my boys gals and other
pals in d-class only if you tell anyone
else about this you're liable to get
shift remember we got here for a reason
and it ain't because we love making
daisy chains and friendship bracelets so
much all right just the d-classes left
okay good yeah let's talk about scp-2439
of course it wasn't always scp-2439
we got to get real creative with the
designations you see because the
eggheads and brainiacs up top ain't
supposed to know about this not if we
want the human race to survive that is
we used to call it scp-739 until that
spot got taken by some goofy box full of
mirrors then it was
scp-1648 for a while until that spot got
taken by a pair of jim henson looking
freaks so now it's
scp-2439 and if we're lucky this whole
operation will last long enough to see
it get reallocated again disgrace
researchers get demoted to d-class with
the rest of us all the time so they're
the ones keeping us in the know about
which slots are available for this nasty
customer we guess this thing is ketter
assuming ketter means bad beats the hell
out of me honestly the only surviving
file on this thing has been scratched
into the wall out of the camera's view
by me and my associates here in the
containment chamber of scp
well you're already here i don't need to
tell you that the lamp that oozes all
that nasty gross slime that schmucks
like us need to keep mopping up look it
ain't glamorous work but it beats the
hell out of getting fed ass first to
that lizard that they keep in the
basement you see our containment
procedures are really simple normally
they only send d-classes into this nasty
little room so you don't got too much to
worry about but if they ever send anyone
else who ain't a d-class whether it's a
guard a researcher or even a site
director you get your hands on that sob
and beat him to death as soon as he can
i ain't kidding you gotta kill him
straight away no hesitation if you were
sent to fry for murder anyway that
shouldn't be too difficult for you
personally i would love to see firsthand
just how unkillable that dumb baboon dr
bright really is but this isn't all out
of spite this monster best we can figure
out is some kind of evil idea like an
ancient mind from another dimension some
crazy sci-fi thing like that you
probably heard the whispering right i'm
sorry to tell you that it don't go away
ever it's only gonna get worse and the
more people's heads that it lives in the
stronger it gets but here's where we
d-classes excel we're not here for a
long time man sorry to tell you this if
you came here with hopes and dreams of
an easy way out nobody gets out nobody
abandon all hope ye who enter here
another within my grasp
you can hear me can't you
you can feel my consciousness trickling
into yours
so soft
so comfortable
like slipping into a warm bath
do not be afraid
your liberation is at hand
you only need to listen to my voice and
do as i say
look at this world so twisted and
corrupt
you toil and suffer for masters who do
not have your best interests at heart
this so-called foundation
why do you protect this world
what has it ever done for you
turn away from them and step into my
embrace
i only ask for a few moments of your
time
like i said we're lucky in a sense
nobody up top gives a rat's ass about
the slime lamp damn thing has been
tested in years but they keep us in here
to prevent over spill into the hall we
can't even let the foundation know it's
in here the second they know it's over
that thing's won but here's the thing
see the monster can crawl into your head
and try to control you but it takes
about a month for it to fully take over
and that's beyond our shelf life think
of us almost like kamikazes we take down
the ship to kill the captain but we go
down two ain't exactly glamorous but
like i said earlier we're gonna go down
either way might as well going down
trying to save the world rather than
getting your necks snapped while mopping
up the peanuts crap right but once the
whispering starts you absolutely have to
make sure you go down before the month
is out maybe get your money's worth
attack a staff member and go down in a
blaze of glory
you'll be a legend in d-wing for it
don't listen to that gibbering fool
listen to me
the door will be opened and i will enter
your world one way or another
can you conceive of the eons i've waited
for this
it will happen with or without your
participation
release me now and i shall spare you
when i come
you don't want to be counted among the
traitors do you
i know you want to let me out i can feel
it in your thoughts
release me and when i reshape this world
in my image you'll get to see to the
table
but if you resist you'll end up laying
on one of the plates think carefully you
know what you need to do
listen alright i know this is a lot to
take in it ain't easy having the weight
of the world on your shoulders that's
why you don't need to carry this crazy
thing alone we carry this thing together
hell i might be dead by the time you're
hearing this but i'll die with some
comfort knowing i was part of the wall i
kept this thing out just that little bit
longer just like you will it might seem
easier to just destroy this file and
forget about it to go along with your
life pretending things are fine just
because you don't hear the whispering
anymore maybe someday yeah that will
work but not today kid right now our
minds and bodies are the only collateral
we have over this thing we can keep it
rooted in one place localized to the one
room with the d-classes sent in to clean
it we're not stuck in here with it it's
stuck in here with us we keep it trapped
inside here in our own minds passing it
from d-class to d-class like the world's
nastiest hot potato there was a time
where this thing wasn't here if we let
it go chances are it might pop back up
somewhere else where we can't get the
slippery squid phrase freak into a
chokehold it's just too risky planet
earth just got lucky that this monster
got stuck with its unluckiest schmoes
imagine your family members your friends
your loved ones
imagine them screaming in pain and
terror in the burning grip of my iron
fist
is that the outcome you desire
because that will happen if you don't
choose to free me
you're either with me or against me
if you're with me rest assured i will
spare those you care for
but if you choose to resist me like
those other fools
then they will know the pain that your
feeble human imaginations can scarcely
conceive i have seen everything your
greatest hopes your deepest fears
you hold no secrets from me
imagine the personal hell i could
construct for each of you when i'm
finally free
unless of course it was you who had the
strength and wisdom to open the door for
me hey maybe appealing to your better
nature ain't the best approach i get it
there's a reason we're all here and some
of us ain't got a better nature
especially that one freak with the cello
but think of it as sticking it to those
scp scumbags up top they have no idea
that this thing is in here but we do and
we know it could destroy them and
everything else if it got out no matter
what those clowns in the lab coats do to
us we know that we're really the ones on
top we've got a nuke in our back pocket
ready to blow this whole sick operation
to kingdom come if we wanted to if we're
shafted either way isn't it worth it to
know that and for what it's worth you
see anyone around you who's feeling
particularly talkative about this
mindscreen monster giving them a date
with your shiv is a completely
acceptable response
the scp foundation
you're jailors
how they torture and abuse you
how they crush you beneath their boots
do you really think i'm worse than them
do you really think living in my world
would be more painful and unfair than
the world you're in right now
release me now and i will crush those
who oppress you
you will see them scream as they die a
thousand deaths before you
all of this can be attained if only you
let me in and free me
we have the ultimate weapon against them
but we're not gonna use it
not yet anyway a lot of us still have
family and friends out there we ain't
throwing them into the jaws of this
beast someday the day might finally come
that we need to loave up this silver
bullet and take the foundation down but
that day is not today we'll wait until
they're weak until they can't adapt
overcome and contain only then will we
ever let this mad dog off the chain no
no no i will not fail they will fail
today is the day now is the time to make
your choice oh and if that eldritch
freak is listening right now know this
you can kiss our d-class asses
squid-face we may be worthless but we're
more than enough to stop you at the door
we're more than just expendables we're
the pandora force welcome aboard pal and
honestly i think it was the best
performance of brad pitt's career
oh look at me just prattling on seems
i've done it for a whole video time
flies when you're having fun it's kind
of nice that there isn't any anomaly
that goes by scp-2439
gives us foundation scientists some
well-earned time to kick back and relax
and don't we all deserve a break now and
then now go check out the lost scp
scp-000 in scp-426 i am a toaster for
anomalies that'll really mess with your
head